et voilà
[Musique]
je lis oui tu as remarqué casimir il n'a
pas bougé du fond du jardin aujourd'hui
mais suivra casimir
je vois aussi visées de l'apli et oui
bonjour bonjour bonjour comment ça va
casimir a un ça va on le dirait pas tu
sûr que ça va très bien très bien très
bien et c'était banque ats-unis on n'est
pas bavard aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
que nous aurons du mal à lui tiré de mau
mau mau mais que j'aime y remédier
malade tu parles comme un petit bébé
maintenant en fait tiquer chili arriaga
a beau parce que maintenant tu pape
allemand man soldats s'immergent est
super papa maman faute et puis ils
cessent de faire l'idiot si tu veux pas
parler tu n'as qu'à l'est dans ton coin
coin coin
très drôle casimir très drôle écoute
julie vient si casimir continue ses
plaisanteries stupide laissons lui dans
son coin coin dans son dans son coin bon
bah de toute façon si vous ne voulez pas
me parler ça n'a aucune importance parce
que j'ai un nouvel amour y accepte de
parler avec moi arrive enfin casimir
s'est pointé à gaza avec tes coin
quoique et momo et casimir julia raison
si tu as un nouvel ami nous sommes très
content pour toi c'est ce que tu vas
faire tu vas aller les chercher jean où
la neige et du nous le présente comme ça
nous aurons un ami supplémentaires dans
l'île aux aurores à l'impossible impôts
s'ils ne recommence pas kazire mais je
veux dire c'est doublement impossible
peut-on savoir pourquoi ça parce que je
crois d'abord qu'il est un peu gâté il
n'y aurait pas de coup j'en ai même
chose et je ne reconnais pas mais ça
c'est nouveau c'est la première fois que
j'entends dire que quelques à un ami
qu'il ne connaît pas je le reconnais
mais je n'allais jamais vu et enfin vous
vous écrivez vous vous téléphonez non on
parle
et je connais son nom ça il n'a jamais
voulu me le dire c'est bien simple je ne
sais même pas si c'est un cochon d'inde
en lapin est un art à part à part ça les
gens qui ne me contredis jamais lui il
est toujours d'accord avec moi lui oui
eh bien moi je suis très impatient de le
connaître en tout cas tu es toi françois
on veut aussi tu penses quelqu'un qui
est toujours d'accord et casimir
vraiment ça va être quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire ont écouté alors on va
aller chercher venez avec moi bien c'est
par là c'est pas encore c'est près du
grand rocher hop on vient là tout à
l'heure
nous y voilà
casimir ton nouvel ami ou est-il je ne
sais pas moi
ce quelque chose
appelle-nous enfin je t'ai déjà dit que
je ne connaissais pas son nom n'aura
quasiment si vous êtes vraiment amis n'y
a pas de raison qu'il ne te dit pas son
nom vous ne me croyez pas bon alors
c'est très bien asseyez vous et regardez
où plutôt écouter
bonjour mon nouvel ami peux tu me dire
ton
résigné à casimir j'ai tout compris dont
une nouvelle amie phénomène bien connu
en force est pas parce qu il est bien
connu quand ta tête phénomène s'il est
si connu que ça devrait savoir son nom
mais mais mais mais je les connais son
nom casimir on l'appelle l'écho drôle de
nom puisqu'il a aussi une drôle de tête
ont pour casimir je suis désolé pour toi
mais le ton nouvel ami n'existe pas ce
que tu entends ces leçons de tes propres
paroles qui renvoyait par le gros rocher
qui est là bas tout au bout de l'île et
se sont répétés plusieurs fois qu'il
avait crois qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui
parlait là bas derrière le rocher tu as
compris non non
non plus d'ailleurs
casimir je recommence
l'écossé la réflexion des ondes sonores
alors toi tu es là tu cries leçon de tes
propres paroles s'en vont là bas tout au
bout frappes contre le gros rocher
rebondissent et enfin reviennent vers
toi et voilà ah oui c'est comme s'il y
avait derrière laurent chez un tout une
niche et de potiron exactement de
quelles niches et de
musc du raconte oui c'est comme s'il y
avait des potiers hockey une mère en
qu'ayant proposes tu veux dire des
perroquets
oiseaux c'est ça noyer alors un peu un
coup de casimir rapport que les petits
hockey n'existe pas ce qui existe ce
sont les perroquets pourtant j'ai lu ça
dans un livre de monsieur prévert mais
oui mais c'était une plaisanterie
mais je sais que c'était une
plaisanterie voyons je trouve d'ailleurs
que vous n'avez pas beaucoup d'humour
vous et a en plus vous êtes jaloux de
mon nouvel ami dont casimir casimir pour
la toute dernière fois
ton nouvel ami n'existe pas tiens
casimir c'est comme si là-bas derrière
le gros rocher il y avait un autre
casimir qui répétait tout ce que tu dis
c'est clair un autre kazinian dupés sur
françois certains casimir d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs tu n'as qu'à essayer
vas-y vous avez vraiment de drôles
d'idées parfois je veux bien essayer
quand même
[Musique]
bonjour
je m'appelle
ouais
bon secours en soit gelée